there's people out there doing bedtime
stories online to help
you know put people to sleep at night
you're doing something similar is that
correct
yeah well yeah early on you know there
are a lot of people that were trying to
help parents out and say hey let me read
your kid for a little bit or at night or
whatever i'll read a book and uh i
thought you know that's not
that that's great but you know who's
reading stories to these
adults to help them uh get to to sleep
at night and so uh i'd like to read a
little bit
of one here for you now kind of see if
you don't mind hyping it on the show
that's kind of good
this is good press for me that's great
okay this is uh rory scoville uh
this is available i guess he's gonna be
available uh reading bedtime stories uh
to absolute ones
so this is just the start of chapter
three okay
um by now it was very clear to the both
of them
that it was only a matter of time till
they would be thrusting their bodies
aggressively
into one another they couldn't wait for
the night to start
and the day to end so that they could
dip into a little bit of the wine
and perhaps each other he saw her eyes
from across the room and
she saw his and she he noticed as she
sexily walked across the room that it
was time to get handsy
and have a little bit of fun i don't
think you should be reading this to kids
what book is this i don't read it to
kids this is for adults this is for
their parents
oh okay what's the book this is one of
my own i've been working on it's called
the devil's christmas
um
it's uh you know that's just the start
of chapter three so you can imagine that
i get
i i cut to the chase pretty quick i get
those first two chapters out of the way
who are they what's their relationship
and i
right get them in the cabin together
very quickly
they're in a cabin okay well it's snowed
outside they're trapped there they don't
have their clothes or their luggage
don't imagine how that would have
happened well if you lose your luggage
you lose your clothes
right you got me there you know um
stop looking off to the side look at me
look at me right here
does this look like i'm looking at you
yes right now
yes don't don't move your eyes what
color is my shirt
your shirt is blue ah maybe you are
maybe you are right i wasn't i don't i'm
not like you i'm an honest person
you didn't everything you've said so far
is some is a sham
or a lie you didn't write that book
you're not on chat another show
i don't have a podcast for a show i just
wanted to be on here i don't know how to
get on tv fake it till you make it
yeah clearly this meant a lot to you and
you chose the prime location
um uh by the way how long where is your
your daughter has been
missing a long time is she over oh yeah
no i gotta go look for her
i like to use uh
[Music]
this is how she knows i'm coming if i
find you
i'm gonna eat you
jesus no
rory no that's not good that's just
that's hiding for that long it's like
you got to get the adrenaline going
again she probably fell asleep
in a closet or something
that's horrific that was horrifying it's
11 o'clock at night what a terrible
thing to do
yeah she shouldn't be up it's kind of
her fault i hope she hid in her bed
um all right i'm gonna get make sure i
get these uh these plugs out you know
what i'm saying that's what we call them
in the biz you know what a plug is
yeah that's why i plug what you're up to
all
all right all episodes of robbie are cur
look at me that's it
just stay right there
this is me the whole interview yeah you
should have done that the whole time and
had no expression
all episodes of robbie are currently
available on comedy central's youtube
channel
yeah and the first the first episode of
dad's the podcast with team coco was
released today
and uh this is you and i having a
conversation and it was a lot of fun
and you really uh you're you're very
insightful you're also a very funny man
new episodes are available every
wednesday so
be listening for those thank you so much
conan i appreciate that